حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره باندلاع اشتباكات
عليفه وقصف متبادل بين الجانبين الروسي
والاوكراني في محيط مدينه باخموت شرق
مقاطعه
وقالت مصادر محليه في المنطقه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحرز تقدما ملحوظا في المحور
الجنوبي لمدينه بخموت في دنيا ايضا افاد
حاكم المقاطعه الاوكراني بارتفاع حصيله
قصف روسي بصواريخ اس 300 على مدينه نيمان
شماليه المقاطعه الى عشره اشخاص وجرح
العشره
وفي شمال شرقي البلاد قال حاكم مقاطعه ان
القوات الروسيه
على عدد من البلدات الحدوديه ما ادى الى
تضرر عدد من المنازل على الجانب الروسي
قال موقع ريبارا العسكريه الروسي ان
القوات الاوكرانيه التي انسحبت من غرب
مدينه اريخوف فيزات بيولوجيا تحاول اعاده
تجميع قواتها والهجوم على بلده رابوت كينو
المجاوره واكد الموقع ان القوات الروسيه
كبدت القوات الاوكرانيه خسائر كبيره اثناء
صدها هجمات في محور زابروجيا بينما اشار
موقع ريدوفكا العسكري الروسيه لان القوات
الروسيه تواصل هجومها المضاد على مواقع
اوكرانيه شمال باخت وفي السياق ذاته اعلنت
قواته لروسيا تدبير اليات عسكريه اوكرانيه
خلال صد محاولتها التقدم
بمحور باخموت
وفي روسيا ايضا نشرت وكاله نوفوستيس صورا
قالت انها لصد القوات الروسيه محاوله من
الجيش الاوكراني للسيطره على موقع في
اتجاه مقاطعه دونيتس الوكاله اضافت ان
القوات الروسيه استهدفت القوه الاوكرانيه
المهاجمه بشكل مباشر واجبرتها على
الانسحاب الى قواعدها